en este vídeo vamos a practicar con
multiplicar y dividir decimales entre 10
100 y 1000 así que vamos a empezar con
un poco de calentamiento cuánto es 2.0 5
por 10 pausa el vídeo y trata de
resolver lo bueno en vídeos anteriores
hemos dicho que cuando multiplicas por
10 mueves cada uno de los dígitos una
posición a la izquierda de modo que esto
va a ser igual a en lugar de dos
unidades ahora vamos a tener dos decenas
así que dos en la posición de las
decenas y luego en lugar de cero décimas
ahora vamos a tener cero unidades y en
lugar de cinco centésimas ahora vamos a
tener cinco décimas por lo que es igual
a 20.5 ahora qué pasaría si fuéramos a
hacer lo contrario si tuviéramos que
dividir 2.05 entre 10 pausa el vídeo y
trata de resolverlo bueno aquí todos
nuestros dígitos cambiarán una posición
hacia la derecha porque estamos
dividiendo entre 10 también puedes ver
que se multiplica por un décimo
nuestras dos unidades se convertirán en
dos décimas así que aquí tenemos cero
punto y ahora tenemos dos décimas
nuestras cero décimas serán cero
centésimas y luego nuestras cinco
centésimas serán cinco milésimas hemos
revisado esto en otros vídeos pero ahora
hagamos esto con digamos 100.000
entonces si te preguntará cuánto es 57
dividido entre 1000 pausa este vídeo y
trata de resolverlo bien hagamos esto
juntos cuando dividimos entre 1000
es lo mismo que dividir entre 10 3 veces
o es lo mismo que multiplicar por un
décimo tres veces o simplemente puedes
decir que vas a mover cada uno de estos
dígitos tres posiciones a la derecha así
que déjenme poner unos espacios aquí de
modo que aquí tenemos decenas unidades
décimas centésimas
milésimas y por eso nuestro 5 que estaba
en la posición de las decenas nuestro 5
que estaba aquí lo vamos a cambiar tres
posiciones a la derecha
23 así que nuestros 5 quedará aquí
entonces lo que eran cinco decenas ahora
son cinco centésimas con este siete va a
pasar algo similar estaba en la posición
de las unidades pero vamos a moverlo
tres posiciones a la derecha uno dos
tres y ahí lo tienen lo que antes era 57
ahora es igual a 57 milésimas y para
dejarlo muy claro pondré un cero en el
lugar de las décimas y un cero en el
lugar de las unidades y eso tiene
sentido hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que
alguien se acerca en la calle y te dice
empecé con 1 punto 0 32 y lo multiplique
por algún número y obtuve 103.2 por cual
número lo multiplicaron para obtener
103.2 pausa el vídeo y trata de resolver
lo bueno para entender esto sólo tenemos
que pensar cuántas posiciones se
desplazó cada dígito entonces lo que
estaba en la posición de las unidades se
cambió no sólo a la posición de las
escenas
que se cambió a la posición de las
centenas de modo que se desplazó dos
posiciones hacia la izquierda el 0 de
manera similar se desplazó dos
posiciones hacia la izquierda de la
posición de las décimas a la posición de
las decenas y si observas cada dígito se
desplazó dos posiciones hacia la
izquierda y debemos multiplicarlo por
diez dos veces por lo que podríamos
decir por diez por diez o simplemente
podría reescribir esto como por cien
solo hagamos un ejemplo más digamos que
alguien tiene que resolver
0.0 15% pausa el vídeo y trata de
resolver lo bueno como hemos hecho antes
solo vamos a desplazar cada dígito dos
posiciones a la izquierda así que el 1
que está en la posición de las
centésimas lo vamos a pasar a la
posición de las unidades y luego el 5
que está en la posición de las milésimas
va a terminar en la posición de las
décimas así que esto será igual
punto 5 y hemos terminado